hallo leute ich jetzt wieder einmal
waren willkommen zu einem video heute
live aus meinem schlafzimmer warum
befinden wir uns in meinem schlafzimmer
das ist eine ganz fantastische frage ist
corinna theil hashtag wir bleiben zu
hause und wenn du auch zu der gruppe
gehört wie ich die zu hause bleiben soll
weil der job entweder von hier aus
stattfinden kann oder der job ja nicht
mehr geht nicht mehr stattfindet oder
luther schule gehst zur uni und das
gerade alles geschlossen hat dann
stellen wir uns einem wirklich
klitzeklein es ist wirklich also wenn
man jetzt das ganze corona thema ist ein
problem nimmt ist die kleidung wirklich
so so groß so wirklich nicht mehr als
das aber da man zu hause außer meine
livestreams auftritt gucken nicht viel
tun kann
widmen wir uns auch diesem kleinen
problemen wer zu hause immer noch mit
einer jeans rumläuft der hat auch sein
leben nicht mehr im griff
keine jeans zu hause die sind
ungemütlich wir wollen gemütlich
aussehen wir wollen uns gut fühlen aber
auch ein bisschen flawless aussehen so
wie ich in meinem los outfit ist cora
nattheim den den ferien dient den den
den test
jetzt wo wir noch bei dem thema sind den
tipp gegen so trockene hände ich krieg
richtig viele risse durch das
händewaschen und creme sie auch schon
ein aber keine ahnung schreibt mal in
die kommentare was ihr gegen trockene
hände zurzeit macht zum jahreswechsel
wechselte auch meistens meinen
kleiderschrank durch das heißt die
wintersachen komm raus die sommer und
frühlings sachen kommen rein
wir befinden uns aber jetzt in einer
ganz besonderen lage
und ich dachte mir warum macht man jetzt
nicht seinen kleiderschrank quarantäne
bereit denn genauso wenig wie gerade
dienst brauchen brauchen wir die nicht
wir brauchen nur sport bh ja komm wir
sind zu hause wer soll uns denn hier
vorschreiben wie wir unsere brust zu
tragen haben sollte uns auch sonst nie
jemand vorschreiben nicht besteht den
punkt ich mache einfach schauen was für
lux ich mit meinen gemütlichen klamotten
hinbekomme und ihr seid live dabei und
dürften so wie immer nach dem video
folgt die mir dann auf twitch denn ich
bin jetzt which partner hashtags socken
tier und natürlich möchte ich auch euch
dazu auffordern ihren kleiderschrank
quarantäne freundlich zu optimieren sie
können es ja mit mir jetzt zusammen
machen also los leute deinen
kleiderschrank macht ihn auf und schämt
euch für einen kurzen moment weil er so
unordentlich ist er ignoriert bitte
diesen teil der ist einfach nicht da
das ist ein super ordentlicher
kleiderschrank erstens wintersachen raus
winter ist vorbei
video need you anymore packen wir sind
eine kiste und ab damit in den keller
dachboden whatever oder erholt euch ein
glas champagner und euren fake
pelzmantel und launcht einfach es muss
bald damit winter
es tut mir leid du bist eine klamotte
ein warm-up vielleicht solche police
trägt man nicht im sommer strickpullis
dürfen jetzt auch ganz getrost gehen zu
warm zu warm zu dem pressing zu warm
wenn wir jetzt alle unsere wintersachen
eliminiert haben können wir jetzt
aussortieren nach ist es gemütlich oder
nicht vor allem teile die ihr in einer
bar oder in einem club angezogen hätte
dürfen jetzt erstmal gehen
mein lieblings ich bin nun bier trinke
ein jeans hemd ist auch dienst- und wie
gesagt das darf uns jetzt erstmal
komplett verlassen keiner braucht
kleider wenn er zuhause chips auf seiner
couch ist draußen im frühling würde die
jacke total gut ankommen aber ich hier
drin next ein kleiner tipp wenn man zum
jahreswechsel seinen kleiderschrank
wechselt kann man auch gleich immer
gucken was trage ich noch was sagt marie
konto muss leider gehen was sagt joy und
was nicht
die folgerungen team kleid ich sag mal
er ab in die abstieg kammer kleid und
geschlecht würde ich so gerne draußen
tragen aber hier drinnen was sagen denn
diesen stopp würde ich zu hause auch
niemals tragen manche klamotten machen
in der wäsche so ganz komischen sachen
und danach sind sie so diesen ab
[Musik]
ich habe mich so darauf gefreut diesen
kurs wiederum zu tragen
fühlt sich das gut an
das sind alles klamotten die ich zu
hause gerne trage ich habe noch eine
andere schublade ich habe nämlich noch
eine schublade mit sportklamotten drin
und die kommen jetzt in den haupt
schrank sie haben es verdient der stadt
getragen zu werden auch wenn man kein
sport macht man fühlt sich einfach
besser
[Musik]
david schon sehr gut aus aber einen tipp
farben sortieren macht wirklich den
größten unterschied
[Musik]
nach farben sortiert das ist der
regenbogen kinder sowie der morgen
nochmal kurze pause sechs stunden später
und nun schauen wir dass wir die
klamotten auch irgendwie zur seite
packen in der kiste kino ist es meine
kiste
[Musik]
das schönste daran ist wenn man seine
klamotten holte die den ganzen winter
lang licht das licht der welt erblicken
konnten wird es sich immer so an als ob
man neue sachen hat neue alte sachen
über mich hätte sachen wird nicht so
gemütlich sein obwohl diese politik cool
aus der frühlings pulli schwarze
klamotten sind zwar cool aber in dieser
die pressing phase in unserem leben
brauchen wir bund und die hälfte von
euch guckt wahrscheinlich gerade auf
sein kleiderschrank und da ist nichts
gutes damit ist gut ich sehe auch gerade
hier sind ein paar klamotten drin
die noch zu eng sind ich dachte ich
werde über den winter folgt wie sport
machen und ich passe immer noch nicht
die sachen reinigt hat dass die dass das
wird hier wieder ganz schnell zu gemacht
wir brauchen die kiste darunter da
kommen wir erst mal die klamotten rein
wie wir die nächsten tage nicht brauchen
und falls ihr euch fragt ja ich werde
auch in jogginghose zum supermarkt gehen
und die kiste kommt jetzt weg und jetzt
schauen was für cooles teilt wir für
zuhause kreieren können ich will
schlafen
zuerst probieren wir ein paar kombi
teile kommen teile sind richtig
praktisch weil sie wirken als ob man
sein leben im griff hat und trotzdem
kann man schön outfit nummer eins ins
corona den
und was mir besonders gut gefällt ist
dass es einen 90er popstar tajine bade
die neunziger sind doch gerade wieder in
kombi teil nummer zwei ist eine nicht so
ganz sexy pussycat dolls pussycat dolls
die hatten auch mal so lieben cappuccino
dieses kurz bringt mich um aber
natürlich hat mich jeder kombi teile zu
hause deswegen kommt jetzt zu den
jogginghosen
vielleicht sollte ich mir socken
anziehen passend zum thema gibt es
frische socken jogginghosen sind schon
lange nicht mehr nur zuhause klamotten
sie können cool aussehen kombiniert mit
einem lässigen t-shirt hoch geknüpft
damit man noch ein bisschen sexy
aussieht schon habt ihr ein cooles
outfit für zu hause
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann doch mal im supermarkt
müsst kein problem ihr nehmt euch eure
absolute lieblingstasche und könnt euer
outfit auf wo ist das ein cooles outfit
ohne quarantäne wäre ich nie darauf
gekommen dass so zu kombinieren und so
springt ihr den zwei meter oder wie wäre
es mit 50 shades auch zu hause kann
keiner eure ideen cha cha und jetzt
endgegner jetzt habe ich das spiel
durchgespielt
ich liebe auch einfach diese tasche
natürlich gibt es aber auch engel
jogginghosen und die kann man perfekt
mit oversize t shirt tragen cute
oversized shirts sind ja schon cool an
sich aber ich finde ich fühle mich damit
immer so ein bisschen zu chillig und
denkt dran wenn ihr den supermarkt geht
[Musik]
ich entdecke gerade in ganz neuen style
an mir
[Musik]
aber hier gibt es natürlich auch wieder
die sexy variante so seid ihr in
schiller klamotten drin aber können
gleichzeitig aber ihren freund verführen
und falls ihr euch entscheidet mit den
klamotten im supermarkt zu gehen was ist
mir dieser tasche los warum sieht sie zu
einem gut aus dass praktisch ist wenn
man sich enge klamotten an sieht
vergisst man nicht sport zu machen
auch hier können wir wieder ein bisschen
zweck reinbringen
oh mein gott glocke des körpers an
meinen ersten yoga onlinekurs gemacht
und ich kann es auf jeden fall empfehlen
falls euer yoga studio zu hat oder
online kurse anbietet macht es bewegt
euch auf jeden fall macht ein bisschen
sport also egal womit
aber macht irgendwas denn sonst fangen
wir bald alle an hier oben so ein
bisschen durchzutreten und wenn wir
schon mal beim thema yoga sind zieht
euch doch einfach eure sportklamotten an
und vielleicht bekommt ihr im laufe des
tages irgendwann beim boxsport zu machen
man fühlt sich auf jeden fall schon viel
produktiver ich laufe auch den ganzen
tag da nur mit meiner biografie um und
falls wir den super g
es passt nicht zusammen
falls sie keinen bock hat auf dem
workout zieht einfach alle eure
klamotten an und dann was ist jeden tag
alle klamotten einmal an und ausziehen
dann hat man doch safe und
fitnessprogramm serie das
fitnessprogramm aber es ist ein
fitnessprogramm und zu yoga hosen und
sporthosen sind auch so gemütlich dass
man sie mit seinen normalen klamotten
kombinieren kann weil hahaha
so leute ich hoffe ich konnte euch ein
bisschen inspirieren euch mal euren
kleiderschrank anzugucken und zu schauen
ob ihr euren chiller quarantine lockt
noch optimieren könnt und ich kann aus
erfahrung sagen home office
beziehungsweise zu hause sein weil man
als youtuber also ist man sehr viel zu
hause funktioniert nur gut wenn man
trotzdem sein alltag lebt und sich nicht
auf gibt das heißt zieht euch für euch
schön an aber gemütlich keiner braucht
bhs und jeans wirklich niemand draußen
in der welt ja dies hart da braucht man
jeans und bhs um sich zu schützen
aber hier drin ist mein sales pace
und wenn ihr zu hause niemanden damit
stört dann geht einfach nackt durchs
leben
ich glaube timo stört es nicht und damit
eine gute und gesunde zeit sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder halt die
ohren steif und bleibt zu hause
ihr auftritt dort stream ich fast jeden
tag ein tag wir sehen uns dort oder hier